ministre mesdames madames et monsieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues ça y
est nous allons enfin examiner ce projet
de loi immigration dont 98 % du texte a
été approuvé en mars et cette attente
nous aura permis de mesurer à quel point
notre droit ne nous permet pas de faire
face efficacement à l'un des principaux
défis politiques qui est devant nous en
effet pas un mois malheureusement sans
qu'une actualité ne fasse état de délits
commis par une personne qui n'auraiit
pas dû être sur notre sol ou que l'on
soit confronté à ces images de camp de
migrants sur l'espace public malgré les
très nombreux textes législatifs qui se
sont succédés depuis plus de 30 ans la
politique migratoire laisse apparaître
une forme d'impuissance de fatalité que
l'État ne parviendrait pas à gérer
pourtant on ne peut pas faire le
reproche à votre gouvernement de ne rien
faire en la matière monsieur le ministre
mais la réalité quotidienne notamment en
matière d'immigration illégale et
souvent décourageante si l'on en croit
l'exposé des motifs votre projet de loi
n'est pas je cite une couche
supplémentaire de sédimentation
législative nous l'espérons tous
effectivement que ce n'est pas le cas
une chose est sûre sans refaire
l'inventaire de l'ensemble des mesures
votre texte vise bel et bien l'ensemble
des aspects de notre politique
migratoire en passant de l'immigration
économique à l'asile et à la
simplification de son contentieux aux
mesures en faveur de l'intégration et de
la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale malgré tout cela a été rappelé
par nos rapporteurs votre texte manquait
d'ambition sur certaines thématiques
notre commission des lois dont je salue
la qualité du travail a largement étaufé
votre projet aussi bien s'agissant du
renforcement de la politique
d'intégration que de la lutte contre
l'immigration
illégale je reviendrai dans quelques
instants sur plusieurs aspect de ce
texte mais une remarque plus générale
tout d'abord le défi migratoire ne
concerne pas que notre pays vous l'avez
dit il concerne l'ensemble de nos pays
voisins et de nos voisins européens et
nous ne sommes pas les plus mal lottis
dans cette dans cette situation en tout
cas l'Italie et la Grèce pour n'en citer
que deux sont quotidiennement bien plus
exposés que nous par facilité certains
sont tentés de dire ah oui mais vous
comprenez c'est surtout un problème
européen et il est vain de modifier sans
fin notre législation nationale bien sûr
que le problème est européen mais ce
n'est certainement pas une raison pour
attendre que la solution Vienne
exclusivement de l'Union européenne nous
devons à la fois porter des évolutions
efficaces dans notre droit interne et
convaincre nos voisins d'adopter des
solutions à l'échelle européenne mais
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre nous avons
besoin de règles européennes ensuite
sommes-nous parvenus avec les mesures
que nous examinons aujourd'hui à un
plafond de verre de ce que nous pouvons
faire en droit constitutionnel constant
sur plusieurs aspects il me semble que
c'est le cas je ne doute pas que la
discussion des amendements amènera nos
rapporteurs à rappelé ce cadre et à
signalé que plusieurs propositions
pouvant paraître intéressantes sont
contraires à la Constitution nous sommes
conscients de ces limites
constitutionnelles c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis les travaux de la
Commission en mars dernier notre groupe
a proposé une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à aménager la
norme suprême en matière d'asile le
texte que nous avons déposé prévoit que
les demandes d'asile soient présentées
non plus à l'arrivée sur le territoire
national mais auprès de nos ambassades
et
consulats nous pensons qu'il faut donc
radicalement faire évoluer notre système
pour pouvoir continuer à protéger vite
ceux qui sont réellement en danger sur
ce sujet il en va de l'honneur de la
France c'est pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
opposés par principe à faire évoluer
notre Constitution sur ces questions
mais dans le respect des exigences
conventionnelles en effet peut-on
accepter demain de déroger à la
hiérarchie des normes principes cardinal
de notre État de droit faut-il envisager
des cas dans lesquels l'autorité des
traités serait remise en cause par
rapport à celle de la loi interne nous y
sommes défavorables si certains d'un
traité nous semble inadapté négotionons
leur modifications si des dispositions
communautaires sont devenues
inoppportune travaillons avec nos
voisins pour les changer puisque nos
collègues etire nous y invitent nous
aurons ce débat dans l'hémicycle au mois
de décembre pour l'ORS je reviens au
projet de loi notre commission des lois
a apporté de nombreuses améliorations au
texte et je me concentrerai sur
certaines d'entre elles l'article prer
vous l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur
introduit une une innovation majeure
elle prévoit la tenue d'un débat annuel
au Parlement sur les orientations
pluriannuelles en matière migratoire
mais surtout à l'issue du débat le
Parlement déterminera le nombre des
étrangers admis à s'installer
durablement en France pour chacune des
catégories de séjour à l'exception de
l'asile à travers cette disposition la
représentation nationale vaoir va
pouvoir chaque année orienter la
politique migratoire de notre pays une
excellente mesure permettant d'associer
députés sénateurs et gouvernement dans
un débat public pour une fois nous ne
subirons pas l'actualité nous la ferons
la Commission s'est également attachée à
renforcer la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale deux articles du texte sont
malheureusement de sortis de l'anonymat
malheureusement après l'assassinat ignob
du professeur Dominique Bernard
enseignant au groupe scolaire Garn
Gambetta à haras les articles 9 9 et 10
nos rapporteurs avaient déjà
profondément modifié ces articles
relactifs aux protections permettant
d'empêcher des mesures d'expulsion ou le
prononcer d'interdiction sur du
territoire français nous avons tous été
heurtés par le profil de l'agresseur du
professeur et de celui d'une partie de
sa famille totalement radicalisée il
nous faut aller plus loin encore et
faciliter la lev des protections
absolues et relatives pour des individus
qui sont une telle menace pour la
sécurité publique mais sur ce sujet
comme sur d'autres ne cédons pas à la
tentation d'adopter des dispositifs dont
nous savons qu'ils seront censurés par
le Conseil constitutionnel nous n'avons
rien à y gagner impossible évidemment de
faire l'impasse sur l'article plus
célèbre de ce texte le fameux article 3
nous tenons au préalable à rappeler que
nous ne comprenons pas du tout
l'effervescence suscité par cette
disposition sur les métiers en tension
elle ne mérite sûrement pas les
réactions très excessives qu'elle suscit
y a-t-il aujourd'hui des personnes en
situation irrégulière qui travaillent
légalement dans notre pays oui bien sûr
sont-ils parfois régularisés au bout
d'un certain temps de présence et de
travail sur le territoire national oui
bien sûr autrement dit le sujet de cet
article n'est pas nouveau et il ne
serait pas juste de prétendre le
contraire l'innovation majeur de
l'article 3 réside dans la création d'un
titre de séjour de plein droit pour
qu'une personne travaillant dans notre
pays depuis plus de 8 mois au cours des
des pour une personne qui travaillerait
depuis plus de 8 mois au cours des deux
dernières années notre groupe a
longuement débattu de cette disposition
un élément central a toujours fait
consensus niz la situation de ces
travailleurs sans papier qui travaillent
parfois depuis des années sur notre sol
souvent dans des métiers pénible ne
résoudra pas le problème soyons clair
ces personnes sont le plus souvent non
expulsables ils sont sur le territoire
depuis trop longtemps ils sont intégrés
ont souvent une famille inutile donc de
venir les voir grossir la catégorie de
ce qu'on appelle les niis ni expulsables
ni régularisaes mais faut-il pour autant
créer un nouveau type de titre de séjour
nous avons finalement considéré que ce
n'était pas la bonne option
le plus efficace est de conserver comme
aujourd'hui le pouvoir d'appréciation
des des préfets dans une gestion des
dossiier au cas par cas c'est ce que
prévoit l'amendement que nous vous
présenterons il prévoit aussi et surtout
de modifier le régime applicable en
matière d'autorisation de travail cela a
été rappelé un salarié sans papier qui
souhaite régulariser sa situation doit
recueillir l'accord de son employeur
pour pouvoir présenter sa demande de
titre de de séjour en préfecture il ne
nous paraît pas pertinent de maintenir
ainsi un salarié étranger dans la
dépendance de son employeur c'est la
raison pour laquelle notre amendement
prévoit aussi la suppression de cet
accord préalable une telle rédaction de
l'article 3 nous semble pragmatique et
responsable ni d'appel d'air ni des nid
de réalité nous espérons que celle-ci
sera finalement partagé par tous nous
sommes également favorables à un
dispositif qui permette d'assouplir
l'accès plus rapide au marché du travail
pour les demandeurs d'asile qui sont
susceptibles d'obtenir la protection de
la France il ne s'agit pas de remettre
en cause la règle applicable à tous les
demandeurs d'asile dont on sait
pertinemment qu'une part majoritaire
n'obtiendra pas le statut de réfugié en
revanche laisser travailler un individu
originaire d'un pays pour lequel les
ressortissants obtiennent l'asile dans
90 % des cas c'est pragmatique cela
favorisera son intégration et nous y
sommes favor
je conclurai enfin en prenant une
analyse de notre collègue mon cher
Jean-Louis bourlange ce dernier
considère qu'il règne en France
actuellement un climat de peur et
d'insécurité dû en grande partie à une
perte de confiance dans nos institution
ce texte à l'ône de nouvelles procédures
administratives essaie de remédier à ce
constat il vient compléter d'autres
mesures déjà prises en y mettant encore
plus d'exigen il correspond à une
attente de nos concitoyens une attente
de fermeté et d'efficacité puisque le
sondage paru hier montre que les 3/4 de
l'opinion publique soutiennent le
présent projet de loi enfin à celles et
ceux qui veulent fermer les frontières
de notre pays je souhaite juste rappeler
que la France s'est construite de tout
temps grâce à l'arrivée d'étrangers
venant de multiples pays et à qui elle
doit une grande partie de sa richesse et
de son rayonnement je vous
remercie merci Madame